hello everyone welcome to another Google
Plus hangout I'm really excited to have
a friend of mine Derral Eve's the
YouTube god they're all can I call you
YouTube god no that's blasphemous oh no
okay YouTube expert how about that I'll
go for that
I met Daryl how did I find you Daryl
about a year ago I was really really
trying to focus on my channel and really
wanted to make it grow and started
looking at online strategies and I came
across your channel and just got so much
great information on there and really
help my channel grow and now I'm getting
this month I'm on track for what seven
hundred thousand views and seven
thousand new subscribers so that's
that's good growth from my channel yeah
we got the replay going on there there
we go there we go awkward moment on
Google+ Hangouts noise Evan it's the
joys of a live broadcast see this is
real this is not recorded rehearsed it's
real raw that's how everybody knows that
it's wrong that's true so I mean a lot
of my audience my own star entrepreneurs
they're not necessarily on YouTube
they're there you know watching my
youtube videos but they may not be on
YouTube and wonder if you could just
quickly walk through who should think
about YouTube as a strategy for their
business and does it make sense for
everybody
well here's the thing Evan and I think
this is the important thing I believe
that everyone that's looking to do
anything in this world regardless of
what it is should have some type of
video presence whether they're on
YouTube or not it they need to have that
video presence because realistically
we're trends are going and where things
are happening you have mobile aspect of
it and video they're converging at a
very fast rate and if you're if you're
behind the way that people consume
content now is shifting and if you're
behind if you're not on this you're good
lose a lot of opportunities and if
you're an entrepreneur which I know a
lot of your viewers are and subscribers
are if you're an entrepreneur this is a
must this is you can't even you can't
even think okay
maybe I'll do it no this is a must and
you're gonna need to figure out a way to
utilize video with your strategies and
I'll tell you why because it's all about
getting that exposure getting that that
connection and the most powerful way to
do that online is through video what
would you tell people who are afraid to
be in front of the camera I know when I
always started I was nervous and afraid
and I know that holds a lot of people
back to be the face and they don't want
to be on camera what would you tell them
about setting up their channel well I
think it all comes back down to is
getting comfortable and it goes back to
a time in my life that I really feared
public speaking I know there's been a
lot of jokes about that that you know
that people are actually more afraid to
to publicly speak than they are death
and they you know they would rather you
know dive and speak at that at someone's
funeral but the the reality of this is
that's kind of human nature and you just
gotta just be comfortable with yourself
and your message and when I was at when
I was young that was totally me I
connect with people on on multiple
levels but once you got me in front of
the this any small congregation 5 10 15
people I would literally shut down and I
get so nervous I start sweating and so
on and it got to the point where you
just truly need to understand that it's
okay and what what how I was able to
transition into that is to think of you
know supporting fans or whatever so I I
think of people that actually cared to
listen to what I had to say and then it
became easy and with video it's the same
concept I know we freeze once that video
record button hits and you're but if you
can just kind of visually think of
someone that you can connect with and
you're talking to them then it makes it
all okay so for right now when we're
having this conversation where I'm an
entrepreneur and I
really em from every aspect of my life
I'm thinking about hey what what
information could I give myself when I
was back starting my some of my ventures
what advice could I actually give myself
about video because there are people
right now in there and it makes it more
comfortable because guess what I'm just
talking to myself and you know I might
need to go see a psychologist after this
but that's kind of what I imagine so and
and for the people who have started
taking that leap and they had their
Channel but they're not getting you know
the results that they thought they would
and it's not leading to the sale as they
thought it would yet what do you find
are the biggest mistakes people make and
how they can overcome them so here's
here's the thing and there's a lot of
people hey just shoot a video get it out
there get it through the door
just make it a no-brainer right for me I
would rather do proper preparation of
the whole game plan I want to think what
what's the end in mind what's what's the
things that we need to do to make it
successful and you know I go through a
lot of things to do that one of it is
the eight things that I ask before I
start anything any video marketing
campaign any video project whatever and
these eight things are extremely
critical before anything's done and I I
believe if anyone wants to be successful
they have to have a game plan in mind
they have to know what what's the
purpose of the videos and so on to have
it do what it's supposed to do so like I
I specifically upload videos to appease
my subscribers so they're happy
oh there's new content that's great I
know it's not gonna give me more
subscribers but it's gonna make my
current subscribers happy that's a game
plan for that I have other videos that I
specifically make that are really geared
to get new people discovering me to find
out who Derral Eve's is to find out what
that is and I have a funnel for them so
that they go through a process of oh
discovery and then they go on a binge of
watching all my videos and go through
that so that's another another way but
the whole reality of Evan is is it comes
back down to is
keeping the end in mind where you would
like to be and how you utilize video to
get you to achieve your goals and and
down the path cool well I know we're
gonna we're gonna dive deeper into it up
the the questions because that's the
best part of these hangouts for me as
question I know you love that too and
the questions already flying in soul so
let's just jump for those of you who may
not be on a hangout before there's a
little chat window on the side and if
you leave a question there for for Daryl
I will moderate and pose it to him and
get his feedback for you guys first one
up is from Jason who writes in basically
he wants to know about YouTube versus TV
what are your thoughts on that and how
do you should an entrepreneur consider
youtuber TV so it really depends who
your target audience actually is and you
got to realize that TV is on the downs
you know you go watch any teenager or
anyone they're not watching TV they're
watching what's on Netflix and YouTube
and they're they're you know consuming
their content that way but if your
target audience is a specific target
audience that will still watch TV then
yeah yeah you definitely want to go
after it however I have two clients and
I love the two clients I have one is NBC
and the other one is Red Bull two
completely different perspectives of
going after a target audience and what
what they do is they have these events
that Red Bull puts on Red Bull events
and they put it across the world and
each little area has a different event
well in my backyard there's an event
that they do and it's where they write a
mountain bike down the cliff they call
it the Red Bull Rampage and NBC Sports
picks it up and and Red Bull does the
same thing the exposure that that event
gets online is about 80 times more than
they do on on ABC or sorry on NBC
it's because the audience is that's what
they want to consume even though it's a
really really good put to get their
production on with NBC the reality of it
it just it resonates higher and higher
higher with that now a lot of you might
say okay well my target audience is
still watching TV and we need to do it I
say do you know what you need to do both
if if that's the case we just landed a
pretty big contract and so we're doing a
whole broadcast strategy that people are
watching on TV but we're trying to push
them over to the online funnels because
once you get online you can track him
you know exactly their behaviors and
what they're able to do and you can
segment them down to your sales funnels
so he's also asking can youtubers learn
from TV shows and how they're marketing
and how they're running themselves what
can you do is learn from some successful
TV programs no I think programs like
reality shows yes I think that you can
learn a lot from the content creation
portion of it how they keep you hooked
would be another thing but the format is
completely different I don't think that
it's even remotely close I know it's not
close it's it's common mistake that they
think oh I can do a TV program and put
it on online and it just doesn't go off
the best example of merging it and I
believe Jimmy Fallon's team is just
brilliant they've merged that platform
with online and they get a lot more
exposure online and they do they do
things on TV that's geared for the
online market and it just basically
feeds its other and it feeds itself
Ellen does the same thing just brilliant
when it comes back down to these
strategies and they have a really good
pulse on trending topics and they have
an audience that can grow and and you
know go from there so you can blend it
together but if you watch if you go and
see if you go into Jimmy Fallon's
channel or Ellen's channel and you see
what's most watch there's a specific
type of video the format of the the
formula behind it and it's the same and
you go watch to see what all successful
videos that they have and it keeps that
same format and that format is just
really really simple it can't be the
longest thing it definitely needs to it
be entertained you know entertaining in
that in that regard
for that specific channel but they hook
you in and they do something to keep you
watching and they engage you to share
that content and you watch each one of
those guarantee they have that in them
in their their formula yeah those are
some great examples I love the gym we
found stuff online is great
next one wait wait wait do you watch him
over over TV - no I don't I don't I
don't have cable
I don't either and that's that's the
whole thing is you know TV itself is is
losing the battle that's why people are
buying other technologies and stuff
because you know these content creators
I think I think Netflix literally is
changing the way that people consume
content first off with movies but now
with independent series I mean some of
their stuff is just brilliant
and you know they're women Emmys all
this other stuff and now you know Yahoo
and AOL and Amazon all these big players
now are creating their own series and
that's gonna really kill these big
broadcast television stations so yeah
and I'm sure if you looked at YouTube if
you thought of them as a cable provider
they'd have a bigger audience and any
other cable provider out there it's true
yeah oh yeah next question new future
builder is he has a hard work question
so we're jumping all over the place here
uh he's he's asking how does he get an
external mic to work with an iPad or
mobile device so he can film and use the
audio from the same device instead of
having to use an external device so so
when you say external are we talking
just a lavalier mic is that what he's
asking or I think anything I think I
think he doesn't what he doesn't want to
do is have to shoot video with this idea
and have like a separate audio recorder
okay so so basically if you're looking
to shoot video with an iPhone or an
Android device or an iPad whatever you
can just go to Amazon and and look for a
lavalier mic that will actually you know
attach to your phone it's like 35
dollars one that I really enjoy and it's
really good audio it's a lot more
expensive but it's road and and rode
mics are just brilliant
excellent Mike's great quality and I use
that one for a lavalier and it's like a
30-foot lavalier it's not Wireless but
it does it does put a crisp audio signal
that's air then there's also shotgun
mics that you can attach you can just
really go to Amazon and just Google that
shotgun mic that attaches to an iPhone
and you're set so and then that sound
records natively to the yet natively to
your video yeah cool awesome
I've never seen an iPhone with a shotgun
link but that's interesting I have the
small ma it's a small you know it's a
small little shotgun mic but it's it's
directional so it's not getting all the
ambient noise in the background and all
that other stuff is directional so
wherever you're moving your camera you
know like for me it's like this big old
hondo camera but wherever I'm moving it
that's where it's gonna get the the
audio right right one direction yeah
next one is from Z Shannon I know you're
gonna like this one there he wants to
know about the process of how to
prospect and convert leads who's in
youtube to sell his services okay well
you've come to the right price okay cuz
for me I mean how I got into video is
all about exposure and then conversion
converting that exposure into what you
wanted it to do and and the first off it
was getting cells and leads are a part
of sales leads you know kind of goes
through the sales funnel but I want to
share an experience because that's where
the reality is when I first got into it
is like 2006 is when I was really
working with video to generate leads in
a very positive way for local businesses
one of the things that we did is
definitely get those videos ranked in
Google and the funny thing about is
hundreds of those videos are still
ranked number one we haven't even
touched it since 2006 it's crazy and I
went to a client and they had a
furniture store and they wanted to sell
sofas and this is okay well let's put a
video together and put it from there and
they spent ninety nine dollars back then
to do this well that ninety nine dollars
that video has been shared so many times
it has almost a half
million video views on it and they've
singly said it sold more couches than
any other ad combined and it only cost
some 99 bucks they've never put ads on
it or anything so you got to keep your
end in mind when you're making the video
and so if you're if you're lead you want
to create leads well you got to figure
out why somebody would give you their
information to get a lead well usually
when they're googling something they're
they have an issue or a problem so you
offer a solution and then you take them
to another place where you can generate
a lead that you can even give more
information because people want more
information so let me just give you an
example if if someone wanted to learn
how to get more views on YouTube they'd
watch my video that's 9 minutes as hey
that's how you get more views on YouTube
at the end of the video says hey if you
want another 30 minute training click
here it's more in-depth you click it I
actually get a lead of a name and an
email address that goes they know it's
you know someone that's hot and you can
go take them through a funnel so you
know what type of person it is in the
sense of a quick little survey and then
it just changes that out but the reality
is things have shifted quite a bit and I
would rather create an add a video ad
before I create a video to get the leads
because that right there I can I can do
a be testing split testing and I can see
what's converting higher I can tweak and
adjust and I got I literally have video
ads right now it's converting at 80% Wow
80% of the people that watch it are
literally becoming a lead and it's not
just for one industry it's across the
board for multiple industries and it's
taking them through the process
I just finished we were at two
California just finished a video right
now I think it's my best project yet I
think it's gonna literally convert at
90% and because I just been doing this
for a very long time and so it's getting
those calls to action to give them what
they're actually looking for is is the
key and and I would say video ads would
be the number one thing that I did and I
test things out maybe organically first
just so you can get an idea and then
move into the paid paid ad system so the
video ads for the most part those are
the ones that we're seeing kind of
before YouTube video comes on and
they've got the five seconds of the or
they watch the whole thing the pending
right those guys were talking about
correct correct but here's the thing and
so I am of course YouTube certified but
I also am certified with AdWords I'm a
Google partner and I'm certified with
analytics and also with video ads so I
pride myself in learning everything
there is to know about different
platforms so let me just tell you this
okay and take it through the mindset
this is for all your entrepreneurs you
pay money to get people to your website
okay
and it doesn't convert some some don't
fill out the form some don't do you know
get to a conversion page or whatever and
with the technologies today you're able
to do so much and so we have what we
call the gathering and the gathering is
you want to get as many people to watch
a video or to your website as quickly as
possible now with the technology is we
can actually remarket them we can
actually set a pixel or if they watch a
video if we tie it into our AdWords
account
we literally contract that person for
540 days so anytime between 540 days we
can interact with that person so we
actually gather them then together now
we can say I want to serve an ad to
anyone that's went to my website that
didn't fill out the form and haven't
liked me on Facebook or haven't
subscribed my YouTube channel I want
them to see that video ad so basically
you're narrowing after that gathering
you're narrowing it down to a specific
target audience that's why the
conversion is so high hey I just noticed
that you was on my website and you
didn't fill out the form you had a lot
of interest coming to the website and
learning about this stuff I have another
offer for you so you can do it another
upsell it down so or whatever and when
they watch that and get to a conversion
page you say okay now you start
segmenting your list out and you really
take it down the process and the power
behind
is really getting these custom
combinations to serving the right ads to
the right people and you're using the
right language and the right tone to get
them to convert so if I haven't done any
advertising campaigns on YouTube yet
what what am i what's a good budget to
start with how much do I need to put
into this to see if it's gonna $0 I
wouldn't do anything quite yet what you
need to do is learn about some
technologies that's out there first
because if not you're just throwing
money away and YouTube will help you
spend that money very very quickly
and and so will Facebook the thing that
you need to learn is everything about
tagging and segmentation that right
there will get you to or hire someone
that understands this that right there
will get you the conversions so the the
reality is is when someone comes on
there's if you set up your website right
if you set up your YouTube channel right
if you get all the stuff integrated when
someone goes to your website you can
serve them a Facebook ad that goes into
their newsfeed plus you can send them a
YouTube video and you get that top of
mind awareness because you need like
seven touches with that client before
they feel comfortable enough to really
go through that process to to purchase
let me give you a perfect example of
this I have a higher end training I only
had 50 spots is like $5,000 a piece and
basically what it was was a training
program that we were offering and all I
did is through ads and I sold out in two
days and I because it was a good
segmented list I had the right ad that
converted and I just didn't really do
anything besides put on that conference
so great it's great it's a good example
and you can also watch their leaves his
videos and channels but he talks a lot
about all this stuff definitely do yeah
educated before you start spending money
for sure okay sign santosh reading in
were do you buy a camera we're starting
a youtube channel so it depends on what
type of camera that you're looking for
the vet best webcam out there is the
logitech series i like the nine 20s in
the nine 30s the nine twenty is probably
the best
so clear camera that you can get for a
webcam the nine 30s are pretty dynamic
too but you can just type in in Amazon
you know nine thirty or whatever that's
just it for webcam you know what we're
doing right now that's what I'm on I'm
on a nine twenty right now and just
crisp crisp video the other types of
things just use your phone I mean your
phone will do everything that you need
to do my kids are making videos right
now that literally hands-down are better
than 90% of the stuff that are shot with
these DSLR and people that don't know
what they're doing and they're doing it
right from their phone just keep in mind
that audio quality is supposed is really
really important with any video so you
need your video should match your audio
and go from there but you can do
entry-level just little pocket cams that
shoot still pictures a lot of vloggers
use those can run anywhere between 100
and 80 dollars up to three hundred
dollars then you can move to the DSLR
which I love the DSLR videos you can do
that as well and you get the the Canon
Rebel is a great entry level camera that
does a lot of the video quality and then
you can move up to a 5d Mark 3 or you
know C 100 what you can keep on going up
but you know and we have cameras that we
use like a red camera that's you know a
lot of money a lot of money so it just
really depends what you're trying to do
with it yeah so for my channel I'm
shooting this just off of my Mac air so
this is the native webcam off the Mac
I'm using a Yeti mic yep so literally
spend the money because literally put in
put in the the chat here if you can
notice a different quality between me
and and Evan and and not saying max bad
or anything like that but it's a little
it's just a little off and that you know
that the the clarity of these cameras it
makes all the difference in the world so
it's worth the hundred dollars you know
to really kick it up it gets the
lighting and there's a couple plugins
that you can get it comes with a
application that you can literally tweak
I can literally change the colors the
color setting the brightness
everything I can just tweak it and then
you to where you're on a Mac MacBook Air
you can go to the Mac App Store and get
its what does that call this I think
it's like web settings
yeah webcam settings and it lets you do
the same thing you can zoom in and all
that other stuff which is which is great
so yeah cool and then for my main videos
I use where's my camera I use a Canon
x8n somewhere here this so this is mine
just for those of you who watch my
channel regularly this is what I'm using
this is about 2,000 bucks
yep I didn't just start with this I
started with Costco cameras and just
started maxing out their best cameras
and Dara I'm sure you use something a
little more professional now on your
channel but but you don't need that
crazy expensive gear to get started
yeah Dell for sure and I actually just
used a cheap well it's not cheap it's
about $800 camera to shoot all mine it's
a Canon so I basically went up from
rebel to the 700 series so related
question from Aaron what tools do I need
to post a video to YouTube in the next
48 hours
so Aaron's hungry wants to get going
tools for the next 48 hours the what
type of tools I'm sorry what what tools
do I need to post a video to YouTube in
the next 48 hours just your phone your
phone will do everything there there's
an application called YouTube capture
that you can use and you can literally
take it record it edit it on your phone
and upload it that's all you need cool
and I know if you don't have a smart
phone like that you need to find some
type of camera to record webcam would be
just fine but the you can use your ear
your ear buds like this as your as your
mic this works really well just get it
position so you can't see it and you're
good to go you can just have that as
your lavalier until you can get a lovely
mic so yeah I mean when I start I use
Windows Movie Maker to edit simple easy
to understand come
three with all your if you have a PC and
that's how I started I mean you can
usually put your video in there and add
some fun effects and upload it to
YouTube yeah and and what I love is just
the editing that you can do on your
phone I mean some of the stuff you can
do on your phone is faster and it
doesn't take rendering time like it does
on Windows Movie Maker and you can get a
lot of great effects but most of you
don't need all the stuff that it offers
all you need to do is be able to shoot a
video put a little intro in it and you
know splice it together and that can be
done quite quickly it's like I have an 8
year old boy that was shooting a video
last night with his iPod and had a you
know five minute video ready to go in
about 20 minutes cool cool
next generation they're on fire uh-huh
okay next question John Carr do
whiteboard videos work for businesses
they can convert quite well for
businesses and you just need to realize
let me just let me just quickly go
through one of the aspect it it's really
understanding your your audience so in
the 8 things that I do is like one of
the things that I asked for is you know
who you're trying to reach with your
content and then what type of content
and tone should you reach with that
target audience or that target avatar
and white where videos can be really
really effective as explaining things
and taking things through a process and
they can be really really high
converting and I I put them next to
highly produced videos and they're kind
of neck-and-neck on on some areas other
areas they fall flat if you really want
to connect with the viewer it's never
gonna happen with a whiteboard video
they're not gonna be emotionally going
oh my gosh I need to share this video I
need to get you know more people
involved they're just gonna just say ok
I'm ready to take the next action if you
want them to it really depends on what
your success metrics for that video is
but if you want them to be more engaging
the eyeballs and people are
they have to connect to someone or a
message or something that can really
inspire them or you know go through that
process so it really depends on what
you're trying to promote cool Jen is an
artist she's got graphic novels and she
wants to start a funding campaign and is
wondering if if you can help her with
her fundraising campaign not only can
they help you but there's there's a lot
of things that you can actually do so
you if you're doing a graphic novel I
would assume that you're going to
probably do something on Kickstarter or
something related to Kickstarter well
you can actually get your fans and if
you do have any fans or grow a fanbase
by posting YouTube videos and there's
another service called patreon that I'd
encourage you to get set up with and
basically anytime you upload a video
people will give you money and so people
will set their their amount so if they
say oh I'm gonna upload a video and I'll
ever eat I'm that she uploads a video
then I you know I'll give her a dollar
or five dollars or ten dollars and then
they get some added benefit from there
and and go from that that portion so
what I would do if it was me do the
patreon model you know release your
content to help get the word out and
you'll have to think strategically on
that but once you get people watching
the video then you can start remarketing
them to other things hey this is a
Kickstarter idea or you can kind of move
them into that that approach and go from
there and so there's multiple aspects of
multiple applications for it what I
would do is if your your end goal your
success metrics is to sell the graphic
novel novel I would look at how you can
grow an audience that would be
interested in the novel first and so
we've done that with authors before
especially with those type of novels
that they would actually release you
know portions at each time kind of drip
it out and what's really effective is
writing the first two or three chapters
and giving it away for free and then
fundraising to have you finish the novel
so great just so you know people are
loving all the answers there right and
then thank you for the answer Darrell
great answer there
thanks a lot so there they're loving the
feedback to the parts that's great great
another I guess related question an
artist who does speed paintings on
YouTube and is wondering if it's a bag
called to ask people for money in
donations to support her art patreon is
another thing that I would say there
just get patreon and then go from there
and then I would do sponsorship deals
with the products that you actually use
so if you use a certain type of paint
contact them say hey I have this this
audience right here they're engaged I
can lead them towards your your page or
do it let's say I'm a user of these and
and they can give you free material but
they'll also pay you for it quite quite
if you work the right deal they can pay
quite a bit I love that that's an
awesome idea
talk to the paint company it's great or
any of the supplies I mean they have
tons of supplies you know one thing you
can do is you do the speed painting of
it which is great what if you slowed it
down and gave a tutorial on why you're
doing the certain things and then you
sold that there's a lot of people that's
want to see it but they also want to
replicate it so yeah and so many people
think just making money from advertising
or just trying to sell people that are a
product or whatever and here's a legit
way to make money by connecting with
sponsors and brand deals so okay I love
it
um brick Dodger brick doctor is one of
one of your subscribers I think yes yeah
so welcome brick Dodger right in this
day how do you promote a movie on
YouTube well that the movie industry has
it down quite well they do you know your
teaser that comes out first and then it
moves into the teaser trailer and then
it goes through the trailer then you
have another trailer and so on before
you do it and it's just kind of dripping
excitement out over a period of time so
I would definitely do a teaser I
definitely do a teaser trailer and I
definitely do one or two trailers for it
you know just kind of give a taste of it
now how would you actually promote it it
really depends on
you know who is supposed to reach like
there's a lot of independent films that
that don't get the exposure that they
want and they could they could get a lot
more exposure if they got the right
people pushing it so influencer
marketing is the approach that I would
take with movies there are people that
have audiences big audiences and if they
love the content that you're that you're
showing them give them a preview or a
private screening then they'll help you
push it and and a lot of people will do
it for free
they won't even ask money for it and
then they'll you know expose that
trailer or teaser to a specific there
their audience and you'll be able to
grow the audience and go from there so
next up Aaron how do you get over the
fear when you worry the people that you
know might find your video so says your
parents your friends potential employers
might see your video on YouTube how do
you get over that fear of still posting
it up stat are you talking about just
the fear of posting it up well you know
at the end of the day it comes back down
to a couple key things and and one is
you're gonna face your fears I think
that's what you teach evidence you gotta
believe in yourself you need to believe
in your cause and the best way to get
over any type of fear is just to do it
and you're gonna make mistakes and it's
not gonna be the best one out there
but doing it gets you more confident and
the more confident you get the more
natural you get the more naturally get
the more engaging you get the more
engaging and get then you have a perfect
combination of doing what you want to to
achieve so I love it Darrell spread some
believe there that's right okay you know
the next question is interesting I
haven't heard you answer this one before
and I've watched a lot of your videos
Jennifer writes in who are your favorite
youtubers that you keep an eye on and
why do they stand out to you well I
would be really biased on my favorite
youtubers it's probably projects that
I've I'm working on like my favorite
youtuber right now is a group called
Studio C I've been working with them for
a year
they are by far the most brilliant
writers of sketch comedy I've ever seen
you know we got one video that has over
a hundred million video views and
collectively just over the year period
they went from about it was like 20
million to over you know almost we're
just pushing a hundred and seventy
seventy-five million video views in that
amount of time just brilliant they're
probably my favorite because it appeals
to my whole family okay I can literally
feel safe and and watch those sketches
with my kids in fact the kids are the
ones that actually exposed me to it
before I even know who they were and
just family-friendly content so I'd say
they're probably my favorite right now I
probably watch the most but they're also
a client too so I know I'm a little
skewed there but but they're funny I I
just laugh I laugh quite a bit but other
than that the ones that I really enjoy
our product review individuals people
that give me more tips on very very
technical things and if I was gonna go
to my I mean I subscribe to a lot of
people and I watch a lot of videos I
mean a lot of videos and let me just go
through my subscriber I can't even name
but my feet I mean like some of the
things I have in my feet are just very
technical video things like green screen
or other ideas or I subscribe to all the
google channels that are out there and
some of them I mean I literally watch
every video of those and some of them
are like three hours long every you know
once every week or whatever on some of
them and it's just Google you know
presenting you know some technologies to
their their employees and so on but you
know I I think the thing that I could
probably consume more you know in that
is probably podcasts I'm kind of a
podcast junkie to do a lot of audiobooks
stuff like that but for me my
entertaining I always like to be
entertained of course but I love to
and I want to learn at a very very fast
rate I don't want to wait and so I I try
to figure out what I want to learn and I
find people that can teach me what I
want to learn it's like right now I'm
the audio book that I'm listening to is
pretty funny my wife's like man you're
just weird and I'm like you married me
oh yeah it's like I I want I like I want
to be well-rounded and so my oh let me
push pause here the book that I'm in and
I'm like almost eight hours into it it's
like Einstein's relativity relativity
and quantum revolution and I'm like oh I
want to consume content it's not always
business-related it's not always fun but
I want I want to learn and I want to
learn by experience experiencing it so I
have an odd viewing habit so I don't
know if that answers the question but I
I don't think there's one specific
person that all I do is oh if I can only
meet them or whatever because I just go
to consume content and to learn you know
from that I subscribe to a lot of
channels there's only a few that I have
to watch every video of and Derral is
one of them oh wow Hajis writes in how
do you get that banner on my videos the
one that says Derral Eve's
oh so this one right here that we have
guests over on this side right so
basically there's a tool called Hangout
toolbox and you can go into any photo
manipulation type of program you can
even use [ __ ] is a free one that you can
get there Pixlr is one that you can use
online and all you're doing is creating
a transparent PNG file and so you can
kind of position it and you just do the
I believe it's like 280 by 720 is the
the ratio from it and then you can kind
of do it from there and I like I don't
know if you've been noticing this but
I've been switching between this these
are different slides and you're not able
to see it's different slides so if
here's my face
book this YouTube I could even say oh
here's my family you know here's how to
make some money know so on and so forth
they can bring slides in you know I'm
ready to go and you know good to go
so I mean that's kind of what I use it
for but you can go to a hangout toolbox
and it's under the tool lower third and
then all you can do is just create your
your lower thirds from there so that tip
deserves a little subscribe to me I'm
taking notes to hear I'm learning
something something new to I'm gonna add
those are my hangers that's great
perfect but Jen who asked you about your
favorite youtubers said thank you that
helps a lot so that's good what do you
think so this is from a channel called
business what do you think of PewDiePie
was the most popular channel with 37
million subscribers so there's there's a
lot of entertainment out there and that
there's things that offend me crude
discussion offends me making fun of
people offends me to a point you know
and not saying that he has a bad
business model it works it works out
there I just don't choose to watch it
and it's not that I haven't watched it
before it's just I don't find it funny
and I know I'm not his target audience I
know I'm not that he's brilliant and he
knows his stuff and he has an audience
and he engages and you gotta realize
that there's more gamers on YouTube than
any other any other niche and so these
are kids that just eat drink sleep video
games and I'm that type of guy I mean I
started with an Atari III played
everything on the Tendo Super Nintendo
Sega Genesis PlayStation Xbox I mean I'm
a gamer hardcore but I'm not I don't
need to have the filth I'm sorry so
there you go love it Oh
cutie pie if you hate me go ahead and
just subscribe I guess of hate hate
polarization marketing
John would like to borrow a tenth of
your brain power go I'm only running on
8% yell or not okay you'll like this one
Joshua do you only buy ads on YouTube
and why no and no and no I my biggest
thing is yeah I'm known for the YouTube
guy but really I'm a traffic generator
and I convert that traffic into whatever
it's supposed to be whether it's leads
whether it sells whether its branding
exposure whatever it may be and that's
that's what I'm known for and so I got a
client is the funniest conversation ever
and they like okay here the YouTube star
you helped all these people we know
everything about you we want to build a
huge YouTube audience what do we do okay
we're starting on Facebook that he want
to start on Facebook and they had 3,000
likes at the time and I said yeah we're
gonna start on Facebook we're gonna put
everything into it we're not gonna spend
any money on it we're gonna just build
that audience up so they're raving fans
and like well how does it have to do
with YouTube I'm like well once we build
it up to a point then it's gonna be
naturally pushing to that so you know
they're at a hundred and thirty six
thousand likes right now their posts
reach keep this in mind right now
average post reach of a fan page on on
Facebook's about eighty percent of your
likes is the average okay their post
reach for a hundred and thirty thousand
likes is about fifteen million so they
reach each week about fifteen million
people
new people and we are naturally building
anywhere between fifty fifteen hundred
to two thousand new likes a week now we
have an audience I can do stuff with
audiences i I can develop audiences and
then use that audience to sell products
I can use that audience to watch videos
but it's an audience that likes what
we're doing and that that's that's huge
that's huge and so your your question on
advertising no I think it would be quite
limiting to only do it on YouTube
however I want it to be cross-platform
and I want it to you know when when
someone's interested everywhere they go
I want to
ad following them around doing some
real-time bidding and and remarketing
for that but I also want when they go to
Facebook that they see an ad when they
go to Twitter they see an ad when they
go and go to PewDiePie's channel and
they see my mug on that videos and hey
here's an ad actually he's with an MC
I'm back you can do that there's other
things but any any type of YouTube video
that they're watching I want them to see
my message and then as they watch the
message I can you know segment them out
into a different area and send another
message to them so hopefully that
answers that question
yeah great so I want to be respectful of
your time you've already given us a lot
and there's still a lot of questions
I'm wonder if we could just go
rapid-fire through some of them I'm
long-winded I don't know if there's
anything called rapid-fire but yeah go
ahead just let's let's go for it okay
ask you Tosh I reached 64 subs in six
months from scratch is that progress
good how do you know what progress is
good it really depends on your analytics
I would just see how many of those 64
subscribers are actually watching your
videos if they're not then you need to
do more work on it I I would say you
need to do that at least weekly move up
to that don't get discouraged though
what you need to do is maybe look at
your calls to action and and figure out
how you can get people more engaged if
you have more viewers than subscribers
that you're not converting more just
spend a little bit more times on your
calls to action
James if you're teaching an audience how
to do something that you're in the same
market of how do you know what to tell
them and what they keep to yourself okay
I James I have that same issue because
I'm like okay do I sell or give away
everything for free that I they sell and
and you know consult for I mean you got
to find the balance like for me I found
you know if I do training tutorials that
that's great but they got boring I got
bored with it so I wanted to do channel
evaluations what I do with businesses
and companies and I wanted to answer
questions and do it I found it's easier
just to tell them everything that you're
doing and there's some strategies on on
ads because I don't really trained on
how to use ads publicly I do that
privately and
where I truly think that there's more
benefit and there's more exposure for
anyone and so it's just choosing how
you're going to lead them in and and
what to what to train them on so DZ I
Darrel I'm certain that hair extensions
commerce business want to use YouTube
for marketing what can I do to stand out
okay so hair extensions I what I would
do is is really get a clever video that
deals with the the pains of hair
extensions and I would make it funny I
would make a funny little education
video that is just hilarious I would
literally like if you're selling them
that's all I would do I wouldn't worry
about building all this content of how
to use hair extensions or anything like
that I just do that one little video
that you put a lot of time of being
creative keep it about keep it under
three minutes and and have a very funny
call to action that goes after and then
what I would do is start looking for
people that are searching for those key
terms and and you can serve ads to them
and see how it converts I'd put like a
hundred dollars in and see what a
hundred dollars can do and see and you
need to have a good landing page and so
on so it can convert but that's that's
what I would do I wouldn't waste my time
on creating a YouTube audience I would
if you're selling stuff let's get right
to sell it and then you can build the
audience at the same time and the
campaigns that we worked on can do both
you can definitely do both at the same
time and you can do it where you have if
it's funny enough and it's relatable
enough that people have the problems
that they're going to think it's funny
and then that's where they're gonna
share it and you'll have a lot of
organic growth from that as well so got
it and I wrote a book for entrepreneurs
over 50 how active are those 50 plus on
YouTube it's one of the higher
demographics on YouTube believe it or
not so the 18 to 234 of courses is gold
for YouTube but there's something about
it look like that's like my second
highest demographic on my
personal channel outside of the 18 to 34
it's that that older age so the comments
are awesome people are saying Evan
Darryl is totally awesome thank you for
the answers it's great
Joshua what new trends are surfacing in
YouTube video marketing
that's a hard quick answer button no no
it's simple actually what nutrients it's
all about list segmentation and
remarketing and and how to utilize paid
strategies to make it happen if you want
to try to rank a video and do all that
other stuff that's great that's just
slow there's faster ways to do it and
Google and YouTube would love you to
take your money and that's the fastest
way to do it it's like we had a video
that we were promoting they pushed it
out and in three weeks they had like 200
views and they're like Derral we want
this to hit our audience here's our
audience type we want to hit it and we
want to do it under you know seven
thousand dollars of ad spend but we want
a million views and we got it I mean it
was good enough video that it was shared
and so on and and we were able to just
use YouTube ads and other type of ads to
generate the traffic to it to get the
message out there so awesome what skills
and habits this is from video black ace
what skills and habits do you recommend
to develop consistency consistency
consistency consistency in your message
consistency in your brand consistency of
your delivery making sure you're on time
and consistency of communicating with
your audience and so I would encourage
you to do it what they call a power hour
and reply to every single comment that's
left on the video for an hour if you're
a bigger youtuber if you're not I would
do a power day or two and I still do a
power day or two where I just reply on
every single comment on my video so
Jason writes in talking about video
games do you play a video game League of
Legends no hi Adele okay hey Erin
talking about YouTube versus twitch for
gamers what do you think twitch all the
way I I would do I would do both don't
get me wrong
but twitch is that's that's what the
platform was made for this for gamers
and there's a lot way a lot more ways
you can make money easily on twitch
where you know you have to make
difficult decisions on YouTube to make
the money but you can do both
there's no reason why you can do both
yeah but I mean can I I do want to I
want I do want to say one thing on that
yeah I truly believe the futures going
of course with paid strategies but it's
live live interaction like what we're
doing right now and and that's why
gaming works so well as they can do the
live livestream gameplay and and just
keep in mind mobile devices you know
that live video mobile so in the chat I
asked people what did you learn from
Daryl in one sentence your favorite bit
of advice and people posting things like
develop an audience keep learning new
things just start just get going so
they're taking the message and sending
out great uh I want to talk about your
your bid summit so Daryl also every year
now has been putting together this this
summit which is probably the most
innovative and leading-edge conference
to go to for YouTube marketing and it
ties into the last question I wanted to
answer today it came from John who wrote
in to say Daryl do you have any courses
that help me set up in video marketing
and I thought that might be a good tie
in to talk about vid summit and we're
talking about quickly what happened last
year you said there was a
fourteen-year-old girl was making half a
million dollars on YouTube and in seven
months they took her seven months to get
there but yeah she she was able to earn
that last year so so talk to us about
your training about vid summit how
people can learn more about you in the
event well I mean if anyone wants to get
any training you can go to Derral Eve's
calm I have a lot of training there a
lot of free training and you can kind of
put in the newsletter and I put out
occasional newsletters you know to go
from there but a lot of it's just video
with the vid summit so I've been doing
this for a very long time I got my
degree in in marketing and advertising
and I graduated in 99 and I quickly
realized I didn't want to work for a big
company and I started my own business
and so on that's another story for
another day
it's a really good story you'll have to
hear that for sure but anyway so I've
been doing a lot of strategies online
I've been to a ton of conference
conferences from all the different types
of conferences and I really enjoy the
networking that happens there sometimes
it's not always what's said on stage
that I go walking away with but I try to
go get a little gold nugget and for me I
always vowed I'd start conferences and
do different things that that would
affect a larger amount of people and I
held different types of conferences and
and I saw there was a need out there I
saw there there's a need for people that
truly want to understand video marketing
video advertising and and really
audience development and growth and
there wasn't really one for the average
person there was one that you know the
ticket price is like two grand and like
a verage people can't can't do it and I
wanted to have people that really know
their stuff not someone that's just gets
up on stage and is selling a product or
anything like that I wanted to go
completely away from that I wanted the
people that actually are implementing
the strategies they're the ones that are
creating and crafting a lot of the
strategies that will be in not textbooks
but taught in marketing classes and so I
actually put together an event called
the vid summit and I selected just a few
people to come and we had the best video
marketers Bar None that that teach and
train and and you know execute a lot of
this stuff come and it was amazing and
the difference was I don't just believe
in teaching from the stage I think you
have to apply it and the best way I
found to apply is to mastermind and to
really pull it in and so we actually had
sessions where they could ask questions
and literally try to figure out how to
apply it and have a group literally
respond back to him and give him more
ideas and it was it's it was amazing
amazing conference and I'm like okay
well how do we actually beat that
conference from last year and so we
decided this year and hopefully you can
see my screen just fine we're holding a
bid summit and it's a little bit
different than the one last year and
it's held
the same spot it's in LA it's August
20th through the 22nd and I call it the
the YouTube marketing event of the year
and what makes this different and you
can go and watch videos and stuff like
that you can go there to vid summit com
get the information from there but what
makes it different is the keynote
speaker so the first one this this first
guy is I I would say the grandfather of
all video marketing on YouTube and you
have to realize that what Jeffrey has
done you know in the short time that
he's been alive on earth is just amazing
he actually has the first official case
study that YouTube was promoting he
speaks at YouTube and Google religiously
a couple times a year you know you know
it's amazing but he has his campaigns
that he does are conversions to sell
products so he was the first one to sell
a physical product using video ads and
he was selling a tongue cleaner called
an Orabrush and he has strategies that's
amazing and he knew that and he found
out early that if you put in a dollar
you can make a dollar from these ads if
you do it right and he created a lot of
the formula so a lot of the stuff that
we do now where you're doing edutainment
where you're educating and entertaining
people to sell them and that's what what
he's doing here you know you're able
totally to he was able to create that
industry he also did a thing where it
was a toilet spray it's called poo
pourri he did that first campaign it
took off like wildfire and then we have
Ricky Ray Butler so Jeffrey is a keynote
speaker he's going to talk about some
what we called yolk content how to
actually really make a difference in the
world if you have a message with just a
small advertising budget we have Ricky
Ray Butler who is one of the most
brilliant guys I've ever met and his his
specialty is finding brands that will
work with influencers so if you have a
youtube channel he finds you a brand and
brings you money and then he takes 10%
okay and it'll feel good for YouTube for
vine for snapchat for twitch well he
just sold his company for an undisclosed
amount of money to Bill Gates company
just a couple weeks ago Wow he's gonna
literally share his strategies on how to
get brand deals how to actually get
sponsorship the things that they're
actually looking for the things that you
need to do in that regard he's going to
come and give that and honestly with
brand bills there's no one in the
industry that is better than him he's
worked with the biggest agencies are the
eight brands out there and getting them
with with smaller channels and
influencers and it's been great then we
actually have someone that I think is by
far I think if anyone actually knows
YouTube better than me there's a few
people that just understand the dynamics
and so on as Sean McKnight he he has 4.5
million subscribers he has a channel
called cute girl hairstyles he launched
another channel for his twin daughters a
year ago and they now have 1.4 million
subscribers Wow he understands
everything on the monetization aspect
everything on the audience development
aspect everything on the how to actually
make money as a youtuber aspect what to
do what not to do
he's gonna literally pull back the
curtain and show us what he's done to to
get that success in a short amount of
time and then you have my and then we
have we also have Allison stern she's a
former employee of YouTube has some
amazing software we have mr. Chad here
mr. Chad is a co-founder of maker studio
so if you know what maker studio is he
as he was one of the co-founders and
sold to Disney for like it was like a
half a billion dollars is crazy
we have Mark Robertson who was the
founder of real SEO and he has a good
good summit I'd encourage anyone that's
a marketing professional to go to his
real summit and then we have Travis
chambers Travis actually launched the
most viral ad of all time it's the the
Kobe versus Messi you know video ad
was going from there he was one of the
individuals that was launching it and
pushing it and so on and Ricky Ricky Ray
Butler was the one that was actually did
all the branding deals on that as well
then we have Dan Goldin who was the vice
president or who's the president of twit
Network with Leo Laporte a podcast for
your podcast junk you know who that is
and then we have Matt Ballack we have a
YouTube employee that's still waiting to
get back from me
we have David Walsh with David Walsh
online we have Jeremy vest we have Jake
Larson I just found out that Gideon's
not coming just because they're having a
baby at that time but we have Tommy
powers now I've been trying to get Tim
Schmoyer and I missed him by a week
because he's gone to Oregon for some
conference that's there but we actually
have other speakers that are just as
impressive as as the people that we have
here and the difference would be this
event and you can see the testimonies
but this events different and it's all
about let me go back to sorry it's all
about really understanding the the
material that's giving it's not like one
where you're paying a whole bunch of
money to get just a little bit of
information it's about the network or
anything like that it's it's all about
that exposure for yourself so if you're
a content creator this is definitely a
place for you if you are a video
marketer this is not only the definite
place but this is where you need to go
every year because all these people are
literally going to open up their
strategies I've shown strategies where
you mentioned that 14 year old girl so I
was approached by a father and he says
my daughter would love to be a youtuber
and this is what she doesn't is up okay
we can do something out of that and
she's as well you can't have her face on
camera and there's couple restrictions
and he paid pretty well so we did the
best strategy and in seven months it was
a half a million dollars that she was
able to generate but the great thing
about it is she got a sponsorship bill
that paid mommy and daddy a new house in
Brentwood that that right there is
amazing and now she's 15 and she's a
multi-millionaire off of her often first
stuff and I showed another case study
where a person just posted one video
back in May
and made 8 million dollars and it was
all natural it was all organic he didn't
pay $1 now I'm still trying to get him
to pay do ads because I think it can
really blow up but we do these and we
literally show you everything there is
to know about the campaigns and the
great thing is it's small I keep it
small and none of these people are paid
they're there they're putting their own
money into it to come here to give back
to the community and it's small where
you can interact with these people you
can ask your questions you there's a
mastermind where they'll lead the
mastermind and you're able to go in the
group that you want to learn more about
and that professional that market or
that expert is going to be there to lead
that discussion so that's it you can get
more information at vid summit calm very
cool yeah so I've linked that down in
the description below for those of you
guys watch you can check that out there
all the feedbacks been amazing people
are thanking you and the chat thank you
so much for the the Hangout great
hangout just ongoing so you know I
really appreciate you taking the time
today to educate us and answer the
buddies questions and I want to
personally thank you I know I did it an
email and in Skype but I also want to do
it visually too what what you did for me
today meant so much and if you didn't
you didn't see that I didn't see the
video that came out yesterday he he
pulled together a thank you video and
he's been doing this with other other
influencers and stuff out there but it
really meant a lot to me and I want to
tell you why is because sometimes at the
end of the day you're trying to figure
out why you're doing it like I literally
run a business full time and I am busy
busy busy busy why do I you a YouTube
channel because I want to give back and
sometimes you're like trying to scratch
your head of man it'd be so easy just to
skip this video and not be consistent
and move on
but now I have motivation anytime that I
am NOT motivated I'm gonna watch that
video where you gathered my subscribers
and
put together something special for me
and it was just nice to hear the nice
words and he read them in comments but
when it's put together in video it just
it means a lot it means a lot to me and
it gives me motivation to do even better
and I want to personally thank you Evan
for putting that together it was very
very kind of you I know how long it
takes to to put that stuff together but
thank you so much it really made my day
and whenever I get down on this aspect
of my life of creating content for
people to consume I will watch that
video I guarantee so maybe those there
will be a million views you're gonna get
off but I definitely will it definitely
gave me a pick-me-up today and I really
do appreciate it so thank you so much
cool man well I mean as I said at the
start you had a huge impact on my
channel and becoming what it is now and
where it's going and so that that's
that's really a small token man that
that's a small token I really appreciate
it and and all the love you gave even
today right all the feedback and given
the people answering the questions
helping them reach their dreams on
YouTube so you do a lot and you deserve
it so thank you thank you alright well
thank you everybody for watching you can
check out Darryl's channel you can check
out bits of it and we'll see you soon in
the next hangout have a great day guys